when I haven't tasted blood in a while I
don't really I don't notice I'm not
sitting there thinking about it and then
all of a sudden something will happen
some situation will unfold and I'll I'll
go into were like war mode and I I just
feel so good it makes me just look
around and I just think you know it
wasn't really supposed to be doing
anything else because it makes me feel
so good to dip to be in that mode to
feel that focus when I have somebody or
some entity that is antagonistic to me
and my family my friends when I feel
something
is the best - whether it was the enemy
whether it is part of some organization
some person that had some dude did
something you know if there's a betrayal
scenario where someone at the trace
and they want to go to war
that's when I'd love to taste the blood